It happens and you complained about
it on Twitter, but I not chasing Jane.
Let's talk about change. Did you read
about that girl from Sweden? From Sweden,
maybe who got on the airplane with
the guy who was sent to Afghanistan?
I did read that this morning.
I have never been more,
I think I was being deported and she
knew when he gets back he's going to die.
He's going to be murdered. This guy,
that was her attitude. What is the stuff?
Cause I only read the headline of
it, the whole thing. The whole story.
So she's on the plane specifically
bought a ticket knowing that he's being
deported. So she did it on push.
She's an activist. She's an activist,
but I don't know what
she's done in the past.
All I know is she refused to sit down
and at a certain point there was a soccer
team on the flight,
stood up with her.
There were other people
who said we back you.
But there were also a lot of
pieces of shit. Shut down.
You're making us late.
So one's going to die and look at
her putting herself on the line.
And then she was,
as she and the guy who was being deported,
we're finally escorted off the plane
because she did her research and her
research told her that the captain can
have them both taken off the plane and
take off anything.
So the, the story was that he was
being deported because of ice.
Is that what it was? I see.
I did. I only read the one.
So he,
they were deporting him and then he was
going to get sent back to Afghanistan
where he was going to be killed.
Yes, we live in a weird time when we
start our story. I was reading about some
woman who was devastated because her,
um,
her daughter in law was being deported
and choose a Trump supporter and her
daughter in law has been
in the United States, uh,
her whole life and, uh, being
deported and you know, just couldn't,
couldn't believe it, couldn't, you
know, came over here as an infant,
that kind of thing that when you're an
illegal alien that no one gives a fuck.
Have you been here for 30 years? You
only been alive for 32 they don't get it.
You get sent back and that's, that's
a disgrace. It really is a disgrace.
No, it's a horrible, it's a horrible
thing. And people like, well,
why don't you fucking drug Aisha,
this young girl, young girl,
but believing so strongly
that she bought a ticket,
got on the plane and then wouldn't
sit down. But what happens now though?
What if the guy's still gets sent back
and kill? But she still, she, she do.
She had something. She did something
and maybe you won't. You don't know.
But that's more than just her
putting on her Twitter account.
This is not right being deported.
This is the one actually doing something,
doing something that doesn't
injure somebody else.
And it can inconvenience as people,
but nothing more than that.
What if you had a layer with though?
He had a big gig. What have I had?
A layover was a huge grandma.
I'm on her side.
I know that from the gift of this
sold out crowd. No, I don't care.